on this episode boehner media employees
visit me
you ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to the askgaryvee show episode
number 39 fun fact about the number 39 i
turned 39 in 10 days this is a very very
special episode of the askgaryvee show
because it's the vaynermedia edition
where employees show md rock from
vaynermedia will ask me questions live
on the show
one videotaped from San Francisco none
from LA because stun one says they were
all crap all right we're getting right
into the first question why don't you
tell the Vayner nation who you are and
what you do here a vinter nation my name
is Glen land ever you actually just
started at intermediate yesterday so I'm
on day number two I'm a noob afternoon
I'm impressed with the hustle though
like sneaking in to the first episode of
questions on your second day that's an
impressive start trying to make a
impression on the boss I I appreciate it
all right
what's your question okay so my question
is so you know how Facebook reach has
been going down not organic yep and it's
the lowest levels we've ever seen yep so
I'm curious what do you think is the
role of organic or unpaid content
whether rands always on strategy and the
second fit within a Facebook world
within the Facebook world over the
second part of the question is just how
much Reach is enough to actually justify
the time effort and resources that go
into producing these assets that's a
great question man nice start um you
know I think I think that it all depends
on size scale and objective right so I
think the biggest problem that everybody
makes is there's no one size that fits
all obviously the brands that we work
with here are at huge scale versus let's
say a lot of people who are watching
who've got a small business you know we
we manage some brand pages that I can
think of right now that are so large in
overall size and have done a good job
putting out great content that they're
still getting hundreds of thousands of
impressions organically without paid
upfront now obviously all of you have
heard me ranting about dark posts for
quite a bit we even talked about this
when you were interviewing so for me you
know do I feel that Facebook has evolved
into a place that
that you want to look at 80 90 $110
that because I actually think those
working media dollars those pay dollars
are a hell of a lot better spent on
Facebook than they are on traditional
banner or things of that nature places
and organizations that you came from
giving those kind of advices so I think
that I think that that's the case now
what's the threshold I think that comes
down to the objective at hand look you
could be a fortune 500 company only
reach 1600 people organically but try to
be selling something that's $10,000 as a
b2b product and if you convert for
people and you're making $40,000 on it
and your profit margin is 50% and you've
made 20,000 in profit and your agency
charged you $800 or $1,800 well then you
justify the means so I think it's you
know one of the biggest things we try to
do here and I think one thing that all
of you need to pay attention to is how
do you become efficient on the back end
I think what's separating us and what
I'm excited about here is that we're
producing quality content at a cost
level that the market has never seen
before
right and that's our advantage right
that for you with fresh eyes is probably
the difference that you're seeing that's
what you guys have to think about for a
lot of entrepreneurs that are watching I
know that's a core of my audience is is
your time worth it because it's not a
money game it's a time game so it's
always resources to me there is no
one-size-fits-all for all the brand
managers and the CMOS and CFOs and the
corporates that are watching the show or
listening to the show I know for a fact
that they need to really look at just
the math right like am I paying more
than what I'm reaching right so if
you're paying a traditional digital
video shop $10,000 to make a video and
then you post it organically and it
reaches 900 people that's off right so I
just think that you have to look at a
case by case any sense thank you thanks
brother welcome thank you next I
remember singing I don't care education
I'm changing rules
sorry stumblin always teased me uh my
question for you what what okay hi hi
Gary hi I'm Emily I know you Lana not
for me for that matter
for you for mm I'm Emily McDonough I
work in HR Gary's team how long have you
been a boehner about three and a half
years and I've had some different roles
in boji though real opposite play there
me okay
see my my water was better for the story
of og oh you beat thank you so legend
has it that on your first date with your
wife you thought that you were gonna
marry her and so not exactly true but
I'll get into body knows that story yes
I also want to know what dating advice
you have for women in their 20s in New
York City yeah this is great
never talked about it listen you're
absolutely right I've never talked about
this um so the legend is and it's true
that after Lizzie and eyes first date
which I which was a three-hour date on a
Sunday night in New York City which
little fun fact the Jets happened to win
that Sunday and had they lost the date
would have not happened so that just ya
know it's I would have canceled weekends
enough that was okay yeah that's exactly
right
um it went extremely well I lived in
Jersey by the Wine Library she lived on
the Upper East Side I drove her home and
I dropped her off and two minutes after
I dropped her off I called her on her
cell phone
she wasn't even in her apartment and my
opening line was can you believe this is
it and I was it and we talked from that
moment all the way to my 45 minute drive
home and until like four o'clock in the
morning and we were married within the
year of our first date so that's the
legend of that story a little tears from
the ladies in the audience I love it ah
advice you know so I you know I think
about you know it's really funny having
a daughter it changes so much in a man's
life I think and so though I know she's
going to grow up in a very different
world I sometimes project what and yeah
and having so many amazing 20 year old
girls that work at vaynermedia it's
interesting thing look I think we're
living through a really interesting time
right
for example girls are always in a place
where they're judged by other girls
that's the psychology that is most
fascinating to me that what would women
do in a world where that wasn't such an
overwhelming kind of pillar to the way
they have to navigate through their
lives you know even look at like how
girls dress on Halloween and like
watching all the comments
Instagram because these are kind of
things I look into I would say this I
would I'm going to give advice the way I
kind of like like to give business
advice which is think about legacy
meaning I think the world's changing
quite a bit right like you know there's
a lot of talk about women in the
workplace and the lean in movement and
all these things women are clearly
closing the gap you know the world's
changing so much especially within the
context of the US that I would be more
aggressive believe it or not that would
be my advice and I know it's a little
bit of a kind of a left turn and maybe
it's a guy giving advice to a girl but
like for me I think it's never been more
appropriate to be on the offense you
know you know because of just what's
going on in the world and so I think you
know I think that women are in a much
better place than they were 20 or 30 or
40 years ago to like say I'm attracted
or intrigued by that gentleman and go on
the offense
you got it Alex and uh and so that's
what I would say I think I think I think
one of the biggest mistakes guys and
girls make is they're just scared to go
in for the move because they want to
protect and hedge against their feelings
and I will tell you this your feelings
could hurt for a little bit but the
long-term regret the amount of people
were watching this right now maybe even
in this room that are sad men and women
that they didn't go for it and didn't
make the move and didn't try that regret
is a hell of a lot longer and more
painful and more drawn out than the
instant rejection of going for it and so
I would say a little bit more aggression
okay cool awesome
let's move on James Beck yeah once you
tell the Vayner nation who you are you
do actor senior copywriter for
vaynermedia I've been here about two
years a little over now Jim is that we
said James okay I don't go I put you so
Jim and I like freaked out and like as I
said the new James and you know going
into that's good I didn't hear you it so
my question is this when it comes to new
platforms emerging tech you've always
promoted the idea of being a first mover
yes most brands some brands are usually
very receptive to that when it comes to
campaigns though some brands are tend to
focus on the idea of own a bill
my question is this vulnerability is
like we need to dominate this platform
or in terms of a campaign when is that
you know how ownable is that campaign to
you know set brand my question is this
when does it become at what point a
campaign ownable
by being the first brand to do something
as in being the first mover to do that
type of campaign you know I think we've
seen it in our space right Oreo kind of
took control of like the real-time
content and people keep bringing it up
over and over and Here I am two years
later bringing it up and so I think you
can get first mover advantage in in that
way I listen and this is going to get me
in trouble I mean I think that's a bunch
of marketing bull talk when brands think
they can own something it just speaks to
their naivete of the heavy fragmentation
of the world we now live in right you
can own something for a moment but to
like own it like there's no brand that's
gonna own what brand owns what right
like I guess over 30 years of iconic
marketing Nike could own the sports
space but do they because last time I
checked I'm Under Armour is growing very
quickly and a million of other things
are happening in a world of SoulCycle
and crossfit and like there is no
ownable this is the naivete the audacity
and just like the lack of contextual
understanding that brand managers and
CMOS in corporate America think that
they have the right to be able to own
these things I think here's what you
need to do as a brand from an ownable
standpoint can you at this moment own it
that it matters enough to your customer
to make them buy your [ __ ] right and
like that's all you could ever ask for
and I think people are way too romantic
in marketing and thinking that they're
going to create the just do it or the
MasterCard priceless and it's going to
be this thing that they can put on their
resume and kind of can live off of for
the rest of their lives to me it's much
more about fragmentation it's much more
about being great at your last at-bat
every time you know I always say you're
only as good as your last at-bat right
this shows doing well if this episode
sucks crap it's heading in the wrong
direction and all 32:8 before it mean
nothing as I go forward and so I think
that's how marketers need to think about
that which is do the best you can
what you need to do at that moment on
the platforms that you decide the story
tell that actually drive business
results not this romantic feeling of
like let's own it Marketing 360 fully
integrated I mean like all this jargon
jargon Jason thank you you're welcome
but don't say that to the client obvious
just kidding say it
all right Oh video question time all
right hey Gary its Amy from San
Francisco Amy the question is the
following what's the most important
thing you've learned while growing your
company at vaynermedia from East Coast
to West Coast and how does a company
successfully scale you know thank same
uh you know the you know 20 I never
opened a second wine library so opening
a second office in San Francisco and a
third in LA has been a new phenomenon
for me and quite honestly there's
challenges in it you know obviously you
I want to be everywhere right and that
matters so much but look even at
vaynermedia I'm not sure the last time I
was on the 15th floor everybody's asking
for an episode of the 15th floor I don't
remember I haven't been on the 15th
floor in a week but a month
excuse me like it's it's it's a
challenge when you're one human being
and so for me so much of it as
high-touch and kind of the way I want to
scale you know Amy to answer your second
part how do you scale a company its I
actually think you scale a company by
doing unscalable things because I really
believe you have to know your business
so at Wine Library I didn't need a lot
of people and it was about selling wine
thus it was a different company here we
sell people we sell our hours against
the scope and our thinking and so all
I've got is people and so for me scaling
this company has been doing everything
that's unscalable which is sitting down
and mentoring one by one and spending as
much time as I can and trying to empower
people to feel comfortable with coming
to me now starting to build out an HR
department after a nine-month search
finding mini and saying ok this is a
person I'm willing to build and think
that has the natural nuances to build
the culture and the HR and EQ that I
want for this organization and then
having people that have been with you
for three and a half years you can show
Emily again so you can wave and so you
know moving her into the HR department
as you just heard earlier so Amy for me
scaling this company because I know
look everybody who has a business has to
understand what business they're
building and no matter what you do it's
always about people
when you're an agency or Client Services
it's extreme people which is so the way
for me to really scale it has been
deeply entrenching myself into the
people that work with me for me
alongside me and that's very important
to me the West Coast office is dynamic
you know you know Alena if you're
watching more Skype sessions you know
how I feel about that it just it's more
communication communication is the
backbone of this whole execution and so
more time more physical time something
Lizzie and I are speaking about of how
much I'm going to spend the West Coast
and 15 and 16 is a big commitment to me
so just up hacking hacking away at the
thing that matters the most which is do
I have a relationship with all 400
people and when it's 4000 people do you
have a relationship with all 4,000
people and I understand the cynicism
that one could have listening to that
answer like how could you possibly have
that and the way you have it is by
having a relationship with the first 40
people and then having it with the next
400 people because the stunning amount
of some of the people in this room and
outside this room and in San Francisco
in LA
stunning amount of people that now help
me scale because when somebody's
struggling or screw this place or I
don't believe Gary they're quick to jump
in and tell 400 stories about why it's
the other way which then gives that
person the ammo to maybe jump in and
relook at the situation a different way
and that can you know I always say the
truth is undefeated right and so you
know for me scaling it is by is by
delivering for your teammates and how
are you tell the vaynernation
hello vaynernation I'm Alex Davis I work
on new business and all things I'm an
Account Director here I've been here
about I don't know eight months now
feels like the year almost I'm really
excited for my anniversary um so I
wanted to ask a question which i think
is going to help some of the
entrepreneur viewers but also just the
Future Leaders at vaynermedia
when you're transitioning from that doer
to a leader knowing what your priorities
are and where to put your focus so that
it counts
yeah can you talk a little bit about
that yeah I can and you know this is
something I have a lot of and did put a
little more color for everybody
listening at Vayner in a lot of other
places you get into a place where you
said it right right you're in execution
mode and then all of a sudden you're
managing a team and those are very
different things and it's the thing that
I most fear and the organization period
end of story because you have incredible
executors who who yearn for the
financial upside and the and the title
to then lead a team and boy are those
two very very very very very very very
very very very very very very different
skill sets and so I think the biggest
thing that people struggle with there's
so many things people struggle with with
the transition number one the thing I
hate more than anything in the world
which is micromanagement I want to kick
micromanagement in the face I hate it
and you know it's something I just
despise and it's a major struggle
because if you're a great executor you
know how to cross those T's and dot
those eyes and it you know when you see
the person on your team who's not as
strong and executing you can't help it
right it goes against the grain so
that's number one thing facing yourself
in mirror and understanding and you know
I've talked to you about this and I
thought there's so many leaders in this
company about this and this is where
people get pissed at me most things
don't matter and that's a very tough
mental transition to somebody that
manages a team the other thing that a
lot of people struggle with and I talked
about this quite a bit in the
organization as well is when you're a
leader you have to be the bigger man and
woman in every situation and a lot of
times people especially when they make
that first transition and it's the first
time they're the leader they look at it
wrongfully because of society as I'm the
boss and they try to impose their will
instead of what I think the real
skillset is which has become a full-time
listener a full-time empower a full-time
eat crap and have humility and empathy
and self-awareness and so you go from
what I believe is IQ to EQ and a lot of
people can't make that transition I
think the reason this organization has
grown so much is that's all I focus on
when that transition happens and don't
try to put pressure on people for new
business and client services and all the
normal things one has to worry about now
I'm the leader now this client has to
respect me I need to make Steve happy I
don't care about that I can take care of
that the highest levels it's about
really empowering people
to become leaders and leaders you know I
love this I mean this is obviously a
subject matter I love we talked about it
even yesterday's episode it takes so
much more motherly historically
stereotypical motherly skills to be a
leader and I think people are confused I
think by default people think it's
fatherly stuff and I think it's motherly
stuff it's emotional skills that allow
somebody to make that transition and
really one of the biggest factors in
this whole thing is self-esteem you know
if you're not able to believe in
yourself
nobody else is going to believe in you
and so I think one of the things is look
I got fortunate I got a mother that
instilled so much stuff and steam in me
that I'm still trying to get some of it
out of me so that I don't come across as
like an egotistical crap head but I
think a lot of people don't have that
and a lot of people my family don't have
that and I see it and one of the weird
little tidbits that I think you make
this episode valuable is if you get into
a leadership spot and if you're
self-aware enough to know that your mom
or dad put you down your whole life or
society did or you know you grew up as a
minority or whatever took self-esteem
out of your body or if it was never
instilled in the first place I think you
need to find an outlet to create it I I
think you need to find an outlet to
create it I think one of the things that
I focus on here is I instill it you know
I instill it I I do talk 90% of the time
about the positives I just can't help it
I'm optimistic and I just see it I do
see the good it's what I do there's
always bad but I think you need to seek
it out and and that may come in the form
of extracurricular activities you might
be a great soccer player or an improv
actor or maybe the person you date maybe
you look for somebody who you know
instills that I think that's a very
attractive characteristic I can tell you
the reason I married Lizzy so quickly it
was because she was my mom and so I like
coming home and having a cheerleader
like you're great I love that I want
that and so I think that those are the
things that come top to mind thanks Gary
awesome guys thanks for watching this
episode I like this this was fun for a
human question of the day how bad do you
want to work
intermedia you keep asking questions
I'll keep trying to answer them do you
want the other side because your hair is
so awesome I'm trying to know which side
is gonna switch no this one's it's good
cool well thank you though you ready
yeah
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe